bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo nous sommes au
coeur du parlement européen à strasbourg
et dans cette édition direction la grèce
plus précisément sur l'île de naxos une
île où de nombreux grecs ont trouvé
refuge pour faire face au chômage et à
la précarité
mais d'abord l'actualité l'espagne qui a
dû demander l'aide de ses partenaires et
à la une
des télévisions européennes regarder ce
zapping signé stéphane moreau et
isabelle à pisany même les journaux
sportifs y font allusion
resca t le sauvetage est en une de toute
la presse espagnole ce matin après avoir
longtemps repoussé le moment madrid a
cédé hier la quatrième économie de la
zone euro demandent l'aide financière de
ses voisins il commandait pas mon film
comme un chef comme nous avons fait des
efforts drastiques au cours des cinq
derniers mois
et alors nous avons obtenu l'ouverture
d'une ligne de crédit pour sauver notre
système financier
le plan de sauvetage d'un montant
maximum de 100 milliards d'euros a pour
objectif d'assainir les banques
espagnoles asphyxié par leurs créances
douteuses dans l'immobilisme
après la grèce l'irlande et le portugal
l'espagne la quatrième économie de la
zone euro à demander de l'aide
seule différence le pays échappent pour
le moment à de nouveaux sacrifices mais
pour combien de temps alors que la
récession est revenu le chômage au plus
haut il n'était pas prévu que mariano
rajoy parle
il s'est exprimé pour expliquer et
rassurer les espagnols et surtout pour
justifier sa politique d'austérité
si l'espagne n'avait pas pris ces
mesures de rigueur elle n'aurait pas
obtenu l'aide du fonds de sauvetage
européen pour sauver ses banques une
mauvaise année pour l'espagne récession
augmentation du chômage et des prix de
l'immobilier
il est facile de trouver le bug de
l'effondrement du marché des prix qui ne
seront jamais remboursés le sauvetage
devrait permettre au besoin de souffler
mais la vraie question sur l'espace et
commentaires
la confiance dans le pays nous revoici à
strasbourg où les députés siègent en
session plénière avec nous cette semaine
jean-marie cavada
bonjour bonjour à vous tous vous sortez
à l'instant de l'hémicycle avant d'y
retourner européen absolument
le temps de faire cette interview vous
êtes député européen président du
mouvement européen france alors
l'actualité c'est la crise toujours la
crise la dernière victime en date c'est
l'espagne l'union européenne a mis de
l'argent pour sauver les banques
ibériques d'une catastrophe éventuelles
est-ce que c'est beaucoup d'argent
est ce que cette fois ça va suffire pour
mettre l'espagne à l'abri des marchés
franchement c'est difficile de le parier
de le dire parce que on a vu que déjà
avec la grèce des flots successifs n'ont
pas réussi à stabiliser la situation
au fond il faut réfléchir une façon
c'est simple quelle est la situation
l'europe n'est pas le pays le continent
le plus endetté au monde
la dette publique européenne et de loin
très inférieur à la dette américaine ou
même japonaise mais en europe la parole
européenne sur les emprunts la garantie
si vous voulez la signature européenne
n'impressionne pas les spéculateurs ne
fait pas autorité et donc toutes les
tourelles de canon de la spéculation
sont tournés sur les marchés européens
qui vendent de la dette européenne parce
qu'au fond se dit la parole de
solidarité ben elle va pas tenir toute
façon les européens sont pas d'accord
entre eux autrement dit c'est une
faiblesse non pas techniques ni
financières mais elle est politique elle
est réellement politique et il faut que
les gouvernants se met ça dans la tête
pour essayer de franchir le pas qui nous
manque qui est forcément un gouvernement
de l'économie qu'on appelle fédéral ou
pas ça n'a pas d'importance mais il faut
gouverner l'économie la finance la
fiscalité
alors pour revenir juste à la situation
de l'espagne 6 7 cet argent qui va qui
va le payer cédé près la part de la
france est importante près de 20
milliards d'euros est ce que nous
citoyens européens on va payer pour les
bagnoles
ça n'est pas un argent brut avec des
heureux sur la table que chacun de
ressortir de sa poche c'est un
équivalent en argent qui en est fait
est important puisque je crois si ma
mémoire est bonne que c'est de l'ordre
de l'équivalent de 200 euros à peu près
par contribuable français les pays les
plus solides de l'union l'allemagne la
france et d'autres d'ailleurs seront des
contributeurs contributeurs comment ils
apportent en réalité une garantie à un
argent qui sera emprunté sur les marchés
donc c'est plutôt une forme de garantie
en cas de manque à dison de l'incapacité
de rembourser par l'espagne et cet
argent là il a si je puis dire comme
comme notaire comme comme séquestre
comme garant les pays européens les plus
les plus riches
nous sommes dedans pas les allemands
nous sommes deux ans la question bien
évidemment qu'on a envie de vous poser
c'est pour combien de temps puisque là
on voit que les marchés ont commencé à
attaquer l'italie est-ce que vous pensez
que la france est à l'abri pour et pour
combien de temps on peut jamais parié
sur ces choses la vérité c'est que aussi
longtemps que nos finances publiques
seront dramatiquement déficitaire et la
france en est à presque mille huit cent
cinquante milliards d'euros sur les
marchés financiers
autant dire que ceux qui parlent de la
souveraineté nationale vraiment ils
trompent leur monde la souveraineté de
la france
avec un tel endettement public aylett
hélas pour partie sur les marchés
financiers de la spéculation mondiale
mais en réalité la france n'est quand
même pas le pays le plus branlant dans
cette affaire le plus menacé mais tout
de même il faut surveiller nos finances
publiques et les efforts qui ont été
faits qui doivent être poursuivis même
si les efforts de rigueur ne sont pas
suffisantes et unique pour redresser la
situation je suis de ceux qui ont dit de
tout temps déjà il y a deux ans que la
croissance était nécessaire il faut
fabriquer de la croissance pour sortir
le pays de sa difficulté mais les
efforts d'austérité les efforts de
rigueur sont absolument nécessaires
c'est comme un ménage on peut pas
dépenser durablement beaucoup plus que
l'on ne reçoit que l'on ne gagne et cet
effort là il n'est pas encore
suffisamment fait pour autant je pense
que la france n'est quand même pas le
pays plus exposés cela dit
la menace peut toujours planer on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec la décote des agences de
notation que nous avons subis et qui
sont à l'affût pour aller un peu plus
loin d'ailleurs bien entendu par
christine lagarde directrice générale du
fmi a mis en garde a lancé un ultimatum
à l'europe il reste moins de trois mois
pour agir d'abord est-ce que l'ancien
ministre de l'économie a raison de faire
la leçon à c'est assez à ses anciens
partenaires de l'écu je ne vais pas pris
comme une sorte de leçon de la méta ce
qui va vous taper sur les doigts âge les
jeux les prix comme la parole d'une
responsable qui a toutes les données
techniques en main puisque les faits me
est certainement l'endroit au monde où
les choses sont les mieux aperçu de par
la nature profondément bien informée de
la machine
oui elle a raison parce que il ne
faudrait pas perdre dans nos pays
européens le goût de l'effort le goût de
l'effort est vraiment très important
pour redresser précisément notre
indépendance et surtout redémarrer la
croissance les pays très endettés du
point de vue de la dette publique ne
peuvent pas espérer une croix sur une
croissance très fort l'un va avec
l'autre argent marie canada vous dit que
le problème de l'europe et est aussi
bien politiques et même avant tout
politique économique alors justement les
choses avancent en europe vous parler de
la nécessité de mettre en place ce
gouvernement économique européen
notre question de la semaine qu'on va
qu'on va regarder avec ce sujet c'est
justement de savoir si l'union politique
le fédéralisme est devenu incontournable
en europe
regardez ce sujet
élection fatidique en grèce sauvetage
maudit en espagne risque de contagion le
ciel européen est toujours aussi sombre
alors depuis berlin de bon matin la
chancelière allemande sonne la
mobilisation via nous avons besoin de
plus d'europe d'une union monétaire
fiscale budgétaire est avant tout d'une
union politique faire l'union ou sombrer
dans le chaos
c'est le dilemme qui se pose aux
dirigeants depuis paris le chef de file
des verts européens appellent lui aussi
au fédéralisme
si on ne renforce pas l'europe fédérale
si on revient aux états nations
on n'est plus rien dans 25 ans il n'y
aura plus un pays européen qui fera
partie du g8 l'union oui mais pas à
n'importe quel prix pour berlin le saut
fédéral implique un transfert de pouvoir
essentiel des états membres vers les
institutions européennes
par exemple la surveillance centralisée
des banques de la zone euro ou encore le
renforcement des compétences de la cour
européenne de justice pour sanctionner
les contrevenants à la discipline
budgétaire
jusque-là l'allemagne a accepté de
mettre la main à la poche pour aider les
pays malades de leur dette
et bien c'est terminé si certains sont à
la traîne l'union politique se fera à
plusieurs vitesses avec en tête les pays
les plus vertueux entraînée par la
locomotive allemande où se situera la
france dans cette nouvelle europe
motus les propositions allemandes n'ont
pas fait beaucoup de bruit en france
alors l'europe va-t-elle prendre la
route du fédéralisme
voilà jean marie cavada est ce que vous
pensez que les états unis d'europe
une expression qui revient en ce moment
vont enfin voir le jour
je voudrais dire aux concitoyens qu'il
ne faut pas avoir peur du fédéralisme
parce que c'est parce qu'on leur raconte
le fédéralisme il s'occupa de 15 mille
trucs
il s'occupe des politiques qu'un état
seul ne peut pas mener lui même et donc
il faut être associés c'est vrai pour la
défense l'énergie la conduite de
l'économie
alors je suis partisan mois que nous
avancions d'un bon très nette est très
claire la question de la menace sur
l'euro de la menace sur nos économies
elle est d'abord politique
la politique doit conduire les choses et
non pas la subir
et dans cette affaire depuis plus de six
mois différentes voies en allemagne de
très haut niveau et la dernière en date
c'est madame merkel veut font des
propositions à la france qui jusqu'à
présent depuis de longs mois n'a pas
répondu nous devons maintenant répondre
à la france j'appelle le gouvernement
français allait plus loin dans la
réponse de la france et je crois que
nous devons l'aider à faire ça pour que
nous disions oui nous sommes d'accord
avec une intégration politique de tout
ce qui concerne l'économie la finance le
bancaire le fiscale pour que le khalife
ou un rapprochement progressif sur 5 10
15 ou 20 ans c'est à dire que nous
devons donner une réponse positive à
madame merkel ça n'allait pas se coucher
devant l'allemagne
c'est lui tendre la main pour avancer
ensemble oui madame merkel dit oui à
l'union mais avec un contrat très précis
qui impose une discipline budgétaire
stricte vous avez dit dans la maison
commune vous a prouvé le contraire
totalement bien entendu ce conseil de
madame merkel de ce qu'elle a dit
monsieur charles ble mais aussi du
président de la cds ou mais aussi de
gauche guy fischer d'un certain nombre
de hauts dirigeants d'opposition de
gouvernement allemand fait que si
l'allemagne est maintenant disposé à
faire ce pas il faut se servir de
l'allemagne pour avancer il faut par
parenthèse avoir de meilleures relations
avec l'allemagne et y travailler et
j'espère que nous ne serons pas de trop
à aider à cette tâche qui est une tâche
de paix et dans ce cas précis une tâche
de progrès naturellement qu'il faut un
gouvernement politique de l'économie de
façon à ce que les économies qui sont
divergentes convergent de façon à ce que
la fiscalité qui est agressive à
l'intérieur même de l'union se rapproche
petit à petit pour qu'il y ait pas des
délocalisations à l'intérieur de l'union
et de façon aussi à ce qu'on parle d'eux
la politique sociale de l'europe le
capital travail ça existe et pas que
dans karl marx les gens qui travaillent
ont droit eux aussi à une sorte de
couverture après il faut le faire au
prorata de la richesse des pays je suis
partisan qu'on fasse maintenant se
sautent d'intégration politique que dans
ma famille au mouvement européen qui
milite énormément pour cette chose on
appelle le fédéralisme mais qu'on peut
aussi appeler tout simplement
l'intégration par la peine de se faire
peur avec le père fouettard où le père
noël pour moi c'est le père noël par
exemple que des dragons vous remarquerez
manuel que les états qui se porte bien à
travers le monde
aujourd'hui à une ou deux exceptions
près sont tous fédéraux il doit y avoir
un rapport entre l'oxygène la liberté la
déconcentration des états fédéraux aient
aussi leur je dirais dirigisme politique
pour tout ce qui est régalien et la
santé économique de ces états et un
rapport on ferait bien de regarder ça de
près eh bien merci aussi à bourg ce
point de vue et cette interview express
si l'on peut dire ce que vous allez
retourner dans l'hémicycle et on va tout
de suite en grèce où la situation
s'aggrave de jour en jour nora hamadi
sera avec une député grec mais d'abord
le focus de la semaine conséquence de la
crise les citadins sont de plus en plus
nombreux à retourner dans leur famille
et leur village d'origine
un retour à la terre suivi par thomas
voleurs et mickaël hunger regarder
6h30 c'est la durée de la traversée
entre le port d'athènes et l'île de
naxos pour de nombreux insulaires qui
travaillent sur le continent ce ferry
est depuis longtemps le lien privilégié
vers la famille et le village natal mais
avec la crise financière tout a changé
de plus en plus de grecs prennent en
aller simple pour naxos ces deux
dernières années plus d'une centaine de
familles entité le chômage et la crise
économique pour rentrer au pays
nous rencontrons michalis eva sous eux
aussi ont quitté la ville avant de
revenir au village il était ouvrier elle
femme au foyer
michalis a travaillé 18 ans pour la plus
grosse entreprise de bâtiment d'athènes
jusqu'à ce que l'économie s'effondre et
avec elle le secteur du bâtiment tout
entier avec ses qualifications et son
âge plus moyen de trouver un emploi en
ville depuis un an et chez alice et son
ami vivent dans la maison de sa mère le
potager et le poulailler permettent de
boucler les fins de mois
c'est sûr ça n'a pas été facile de
changer complètement de vie on a vécu
pendant des années dans la capitale et
maintenant on est un peu au bout du
monde il faut bien se dire qu'à athènes
cela devenait de plus en plus invivable
il est des gens partout alors qu'ici
c'est beaucoup plus calme
je ne regrette pas d'avoir déménagé à
naxos au début michel saive à sous ont
eu un peu de mal avec le jardinage mais
avec l'aide des voisins est un petit peu
d'entraînement les légumes ont fini par
pousser
en tout cas ils n'ont plus besoin
d'acheter ni tomates ni poivrons ni
aubergines nous sommes pratiquement
autosuffisant pour les légumes
quand on a un petit budget comme nous
c'est très appréciable
en fait on n'achète que les pommes de
terre et les oignons les seuls légumes
que nous ne cultivons pas même s'ils
avaient retrouvé du travail dans la
capitale
michalis n'aurait pas pu gérer son
budget la vie à athènes était devenue
beaucoup trop cher
le déménagement à naxos s'est donc
imposé
les richesses de l'île de naxos ce sont
la terre fertile l'eau et le marbre ici
michalis à retrouver un emploi dans sa
branche
il travaillait la carrière de marbre
pour un salaire de 980 euros par mois
tata pixel
en fait c'était un véritable coup de
chance pour moi en arrivant ici je ne
connaissais personne et les emplois sont
rares sur l'île mais c'est vraiment une
autre qualité de vie ici en tout cas
j'ai un bon boulot et ça se passe plutôt
bien pour moi
d
durant des décennies
manolis à travailler comme plombier à la
régie municipale d'athènes il avait
depuis longtemps envie de retourner dans
son village natal
maintenant avec l'augmentation des prix
c'est devenu une nécessité
comment payer un loyer de 600 euros avec
sa retraite un axe hausse le loyer n'est
que de 200 euros et en plus il peut
produire lui même une partie de son
alimentation
de là vous voyez j'ai quelques ruches
pour produire du miel et puis j'ai
change des yeux ou des poules contre
d'autres produits de l'huile d'olive du
vin ou du raki on forme une bonne équipe
avec les voisins ont fait la récolte
d'olives ensemble en échange de mon
travail il me donne des denrées
alimentaires comme ça je peux vivre
simplement sans être obligé d'aller trop
souvent au supermarché eu le retour en
force du troc en quelque sorte
attention détrompez vous tout n'est pas
rose ont mené une exploitation agricole
même petit comme la mienne il faut
investir un minimum
et puis il ne faut pas rechigner à la
tâche sans savoir y faire sinon ça ne
pousse pas il faut aussi s'organiser
pour l'outillage le tracteur ou
l'irrigation mais le retour à la terre
n'est pas à la portée de tout le monde
certains de ceux qui ont osé franchir le
pas ont réussi à trouver leur place au
sein d'une société rurale basé sur la
solidarité
délicieux si tu en veux tu puisses tu
n'as qu'à me le dire à bientôt pour toi
bien voilà de retour sur le plateau d'
europe hebdo pourparlers retour à la
terre en grèce et pour ce faire nous
avons été rejoints par maria eleni koppa
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
donc grecque et vous êtes membre du
pasoc quel parti socialiste grec ce
reportage très touchant en fait montre
que la plupart des grecs retourne à la
terre retourne travailler la terre font
de l'agriculture pour se sortir un petit
peu ce quotidien difficile
est-ce que c'est du gâchis tout ça est
ce que c'est un retour en arrière
c'était inévitable
c'était inévitable après la crise
économique et le paquet d'austérité qui
est imposé sur la grèce c'est évident
que nous avions besoin de retenir nos
finances le budget mais sans des mesures
de croissance qui était absente pendant
toute cette période et ce retour à la
terre était tout à fait inévitable et
c'est vrai que pendant des années les
grecs ont quitté leur village pour aller
a eu à vivre
oui tout à fait
et nous faisons de râles pour aller
vivre dans les grandes villes alors
maintenant c'est normal qu'avec la crise
il retourne mais il faut vraiment
réfléchir sur les causes et sur ce qu'on
peut faire encore pour améliorer une
situation qui est vraiment actuellement
grèce est invivable
mais là il ya quand même un gâchis vous
parliez de cet exode rural on a beaucoup
d'étudiants enfin de ses enfants en fait
de ces terres de ces îles sont allés
faire des études à athènes dans la
grande ville sont parfois très diplômés
et reviennent ensuite faire faire que ce
soit de l'huile d'olive ou ou du miel
est ce qu'on n'est pas profondément dans
un guichet ce n'est pas une génération
gâcher en grèce aujourd'hui après on
peut parler même de génération perdue
parce qu'il y à tous ces diplômés de
vous parler que maintenant on n'arrive
pas à trouver de travail le chômage
parmi les jeunes c'est arrive
pratiquement 45 % les gens diplômés les
gens même avec des études doctorales
donc sans pouvoir trouver de travail ces
gens soient ils quittent le pays pour
aller à l'étranger soit ils retournent à
leur village natal mais il faut vraiment
que le nouveau gouvernement
l'europe aussi et j'imagine les deux
ensembles trouve des nouvelles solutions
pour ce problème sinon la situation va
se détériorer dans les mois qui viennent
est-ce que la solution c'est d'arrêter
les politiques d'austérité
les politiques d'austérité est une
nécessité d'une certaine façon parce que
c'est vrai qu'il faut assainir nos
finances publiques le budget mais sans
avoir un bras de croissance c'est une
situation tout à fait vivable en grèce
alors il faut vraiment investir à la
croissance ad nouvel emploi à une
perspective pour surtout pour la
nouvelle génération et c'est ça qui est
important et c'est ça qui est le grand
défi pour l'avenir
alors il ya effectivement les politiques
d'autres de croissance mais il ya aussi
la variante réformes structurelles c'est
quand même un pays on a du mal à
collecter l'impôt il ya énormément de
corruption est ce qu'il faudrait pas
aussi un coup de balai dans la classe
politique qui n'arrive pas à mettre tout
ça en place et je parle là la députée du
pasok grecque
et vous savez le pain dont les élections
du 6 mai parce qu'ils étaient punis
pratiquement parce que c'était le parti
qu'ils étaient obligés du pouce
poursuivre la politique de l'austérité
des rigueurs et le parti qui était au
pouvoir avec la nea dimokratia pendant
beaucoup d'années
mais maintenant le passé aucun seuil et
de tirer la ligne avec le passé et de
recommencer mais on va voir si
l'électorat va vraiment croire un autre
nouveau message c'est pas évident c'est
pas facile parce que c'est vrai que
pendant ces deux années
on n'a plus vraiment coupé les pensions
elle les salaires des gens mais on
n'était pas efficace au niveau de ce
dont vous parlez les réformes
structurelles
elle a aussi avec la croissance est le
deuxième grand défi pour le pays oui
mais elle vous parlez de la croissance
comme si c'était une profession de foi
une religion comme si on le provoquait
comme ça d'un claquement de doigts c'est
quand même pas aussi simple s'il n'y a
pas eu de réforme structurelle
est-ce que derrière forcément il y aura
une politique de croissance même si on
met l'argent sur la table
rien n'est évident le fait c'est comment
on peut vraiment mettre un pays sur ses
pieds sans créer des emplois
c'est pas que c'est une personne n'a la
recette magique et on sait que les
réformes structurelles sont nécessaires
mais bien sûr au niveau des collections
des taxes dont vous avez parlé c'est
primordial mais même si on arrive à
avoir des mécanismes de collection de
taxes efficace on aura pas de nouvel
emploi il faut vraiment trouver la bonne
recette
les bons équilibres entre raisons
structurelles et récemment des finances
publiques et croissance et sa cette
recette n'est pas sur la table
actuellement
alors je voudrais qu'on regarde quelques
images ça s'est passé il ya quelques
jours sur le plateau d'une télévision
grecque
on y voit en fait un porte parole du
parti au bord et que c'est le parti
néo-nazi qu'il a fait une percée aux
dernières élections et ils agressent
violemment en fait deux députés élus à
gauche
cet incident fait à on voit en fait il a
jeté un premier verre et qu'ensuite il a
filé plusieurs claques à une de vos
concerts grecque
cet incident a provoqué une vive émotion
est-ce qu'il faut interdire ce parti
néo-nazi c'est que je crois la grande
question parce que j'ai souvent
l'impression que la démocratie est
faible devant l'agressivité la violence
des partis d'extrême droite et je dois
dire que ce parti
ce parti néo nazi qui a la structure
vraiment paramilitaires et au delà de ce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir en europe
comme avec le front national en france
et il faut vraiment être très sévère est
vraiment savoir tirer la ligne mon avis
personnel vie il faut il faudrait
interdire des parties pareil qui vont
contre à l'encontre de toute valeur
démocratique sur lequel la grèce notre
république est fondée mais aussi qui est
contre tout valeur toutes les valeurs de
l'union européenne mais c'est une grande
débat est souvent dit qu'en démocratie
tout est permis
c'est pas mon opinion personnelle alors
à l'autre bout de l'échiquier politique
qui a series acquis et le parti
d'extrême gauche qui risque peut-être de
voir de nouveau essayé de monter un
gouvernement
est ce que vous le pasok et vous en tant
que député grec au parlement européen
est ce que vous êtes pour une alliance
avec un parti d'extrême gauche qui
rejette le mémorandum de la troïka c'est
à dire fmi bce et union européenne
le problème avec syriza et son populisme
c'est à dire à chaque jour des
différents cadre de ce bail
partez disent des choses contradictoires
et le populisme à cette période
très critique pour la grèce est très
très dangereuse parce que deux parties
responsables nous sommes prêtes à
gouverner et à soutenir un gouvernement
pour la grèce parce que nous savons
qu'on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
mais les risques avec series à son grave
parce que ce populisme 1 6 et 7 et
continué le changement de position n'est
pas en garantie pour un gouvernement
stable dans l'europe et avec l'euro est
pour nous la priorité c'est la grèce en
europe est la nôtre perm la permanence
de la grèce dans la zone euro ce qui
n'est pas fait
ce qui n'est pas sûr on a travaillé
pendant deux années depuis 2009 pour
garder le pays dans la zone euro
et vous pensez qu'il ya un risque que
maintenant avec ces réseaux c'est vrai
qu'il ya un grand risque que le pays
n'arrive pas à rester dans la zone euro
et ce sera la tragédie nationale pour
nous merci beaucoup
madame copa d'avoir été parmi nous
aujourd'hui nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles pour
d'autres actualités européenne merci